première vidéo faq de ce nouveau format
de cette nouvelle saison de cette
nouvelle année je vais donc aujourd'hui
répondre à vos questions à y poser plein
de questions
elles sont là elles font aussi dans mon
ordi qui est juste là merci c'est très
simple vous me posez vos questions ici
tout de suite ici en bas en commentaire
vous posez tout ce que vous voulez et
dont la prochaine afin qu il répondrait
alors après j'irai voir quand même sur
l'être comme mozart dans cette vidéo
si toutefois vous avez pas des questions
pis bad à droite à gauche mais n'hésitez
pas en tout cas à les poser directement
maintenant comme ça sera beaucoup plus
[Musique]
non
le constat est le suivant j'ai pas
souvent le temps de vous répondre en
commentaire c'est un peu compliqué on le
fait sous forme de faq
c'est plus convivial comme ça tout le
monde a la réponse là où les réponses
c'est plutôt cool alors on commence tout
de suite que choisir entre le mit 9d et
le minefe light en fait je sais que
c'est un peu compliqué ce que la gamme
de chironi cette année mis neuf mille
neuf est semi 9-9 tétrominos flight
ça fait beaucoup 2009 je vous ai donc
préparé un petit paquet si un petit
document alors je vais pas vous de
pauvreté pour me lire parce que je sais
que vous allez y arriver j'ai cru
extrêmement mal et je l'en gros vous
expliquer un peu la différence entre les
grands modèles et des différences
notables déjà en terme de design
notamment sur le nid 9
le mineur fait ce qui gêne les
antisèches 1 entre le mil neuf lumineux
fait ceux émis 9 lite vous avez une au
coach qui se situe juste là après sur
tous les modèles vous avez des écrans
amoled
la plupart ce sont des 6,39 pouces fhd
plus soft juste le mil neuf et ce qui
lui a un écran de 5,97 pousse toujours à
eiffage les plus gros il va voir un
format un peu plus compact les modèles
les plus performants vous allez avoir le
mil neuf et le mil neuf des pros dans
lequel vous avez les qualcomm snapdragon
dans tous les cas vous avez si jk drame
64 go de stockage ou si giga de ram 128
go de stockage
là je base voyait que sur les specs pour
réussir un petit peu à dégrossir tout ça
sur les autres modèles alors salle où ça
se complique un petit peu le minefe tz1
son dragon 730 le mineur est ce vous
avertissent la dragonne 712 et sur le
mint flight vous avez un snapdragon 710
vous cassez pas la tête
cherchez pas les plus haut de gamme ce
sont les 855 qui vous permettront
d'avoir les meilleures caméras sony mx 5
186 tous les autres vous avez des
caméras 48 mégapixels somine mx 5 182
différence c'est qu'avec la zone yannick
586 filmé en 4k à 60 images par seconde
avec 1,82 peaufiner en 4k à 30 images
par seconde la grosse différence à se
situe là dessus dans tous les cas pour
la plupart des usages courants ça
marchera parfaitement bien que vous ayez
ans après god 855 ou alors un de la
série 700 ça marchera bien vous pourrez
aller plus loin avec les saints dragonne
de la série 800 qui sont les plus haut
de gamme la série 700 marche bien vous
tracassez pas là dessus parfois ça va
dépendre si vous faites des jeux de type
dut forte taille tous là vous pour aller
plus loin ce sera plus fluide ça
marchera mieux
mais bon avec une série 700 déjà ça
fonctionne plutôt pas mal la grosse
différence d'aspect rossi au niveau de
la batterie fait plus on va rouler un
petit peu pour des rennais choses sur le
mineur vous avez une batterie de trois
mille trois cent millions terreur vous
arrivez au dessus en batterie avec le
1909 tétreault des batteries de 4000
milliampères heures sont mieux classés
vous avez une petite batterie 3060 10
millions terreur mais aussi un écran un
peu plus petits tous un peu dans la
balance et sur inside avec batterie de
4030 milliampères heures du côté de la
photo je vous le dis vous avez partout
des capteurs 48 mégapixels soit 586 soit
580 de vous expliquer ce n'est quelques
secondes vous avez un peu plus de pixels
du côté du 1900 allait avoir son côté
l'objectif 12 mégapixels ouverture de f
2.2 vous avait alors 16 mégapixels grand
temps luttera longtemps la touvre aeb
2.2 sur le mineur fait qu'en terme de
photos cette date est celui qu'il était
plus abouti entre le minorité est le
midd a fait ce que vous aurez les mêmes
caméras l'arrière et là vous aurez un
peu moins de spec c sur le mint flight
qui est juste là vous avez effectivement
cette somme yannick 582 à 48 méga pixels
d'un appareil principal mais par contre
vous êtes parfait l'objectif là vous
avez une caméra de 2 mégapixels qui
répondent le la profondeur pour le mode
portrait pour les faits ok on a un peu
plus limité là dessus mais bon ça dépend
de vos usages après c'est un modèle ait
forcément moins de choses dedans et
coûte moins cher voilà les faire des
choix vous allez avoir dans tous les
smartphones une caméra 2 mégapixels à
l'avant sauf sur le light
vous avez une caméra de 30 2 mégapixels
très honnêtement vous prenez pas trop la
tête les caméras telle fille sait pas ce
qu'on va utiliser plus moi ce que je
privilégierai là dessus c'est le fait
d'abord un grand écran je préfère
toujours le petit peuple parce que vous
avez un grand écran et vous avez pas
d'encoches tout ça un peu plus un panier
à moutier mais là où ça devient
important à gérer c'est la notion du
prix or la notion prix là dessus c'est
un peu chaotique un jeu
le fait un peu pêle mêle jeu vous lui
parce que bon voilà aussi repéré en gros
entre 300 euros à 450 euros
vous avez toute la gamme de ce mineur de
cette année le minatd et vous êtes à 459
euros pour la version 6 64 et 628 479
euros
minev t 329 389 me d'acheter trop 429
449 mines a fait ce 349 369 emile et
flight et 299 329 7 ans a su toujours un
petit peu apte à grand chose ça se tient
peu dans un mouchoir de poche pour
essayer de résumer essayer de comprendre
sans sortir un petit peu compliqué parce
que tellement de produits et vous savez
la stratégie du côté de chez lui c'est
que vous ayez tellement de modèles qu en
rond quel que soit le produit vous allez
cherchez vous allez avoir un chiot mais
enfin c'est toujours un petit peu voilà
un petit peu qui peut compliquer pour
s'y repérer bientôt pour dégrossir en
gros le mil neuf pour moi c'est la
valeur sûre vous à l'esquissé mieux en
terme de performance chez chuo me vous
avez un truc qui est top
au terme de photos qui marche bien mon
modèle préféré c'est 2009 d'éperons
parce que vous avez un grand écran vous
n'avez pas d'encoches de la caméra pop
up vous est quelque chose qui marche
bien vous avez beaucoup de performances
avec un saut à 2 855 ça marche très bien
si vous voulez économiser un petit peu
vous pouvez switcher sur le minatd et
vous allez avoir un peu moins de
performance s'arrête en gros le grand
écran au meilleur prix le mineur fait ce
s'adresse à ceux qui veulent un format
inférieur à 6 pouces pendant un peu plus
à tenir dans la main tandis que l'unef
lights et le rapport qualité prix
le fait d'abord un smartphone shiomi qui
marche bien qu'une caméra 48 min pixels
moins cher j'espère vous avoir [ __ ] je
sais que c'est un peu compliqué il ya
beaucoup de références et chimiques
mais bon voilà c'est comme ça question
suivante dix mois avant de souhaiter
dans ton garage ou bien dans un vrai
studio le studio d'avant c'était une
pièce dédiée juste en dessous de chez
moi qui ne servent de studio et puis
d'un peu autre chose ne s'endort pas
dans une prochaine vidéo vous allez voir
robert tourné il ya en tout cas tourné
là-bas on en reparle bientôt pourquoi ne
serais tu pas des live
youtube où tu répondre directement aux
questions posées dans les commentaires
ce serait plus simple et plus convivial
non oui on va faire ça très
prochainement
tous les dimanches il faut juste que je
change du trap truc un peu technique
chez moi parce que le dimanche je suis
chez moi je me suis pas attardé je suis
donc à clairement ils m'accostent
internet allez un petit peu moyenne ce
qui fait que si je veux pouvoir
effectivement faire de live avec ce que
j'ai actuellement au risque est un petit
peu compliqué non va en faire c'est pas
le tracé qui monde réagir de pouvoir
parler ensemble communiqué savez ça a
été assez cool super nouveau projet il
ya des toilettes au moins où il ya des
toiles de tout est là bas ça a été très
utile du coup la question que je me pose
avec tout ce que tu fais et tout ce que
tu prévois de faire pour un seul homme
c'est beaucoup tournage montage vidéo
battu pour ça travaille avec une autre
personne
c'est une question que je me pose pour
2020 peut-être must a fait avec un
moteur ou une monteuse pour pouvoir
effectivement déléguer cette partie là
qui est partie que j'aime bien parce que
c'est la partie un peu la plus créative
mais qui prend beaucoup de temps à voir
en 2020 on en reparle félicitations à
vous générez glané ya beaucoup de
courage au nahd est dédié à minya
objectif combien d'abonnés d'ici un an
normal moi j'avais annoncé un objectif
de 500 milles fin d'année on n'y sera
pas 300 mais ça serait bien à quelque
chose près d'ailleurs si vous voulez
partager potins dès maintenant comme ça
vous ramener tous vos potes et votre
famille cas ça marche et nous les
podcasts seront sur quels sites
applications
on en reparle bientôt les podcasts
lorsque j'aurais fait ce que ça sera en
ligne je ferai une vidéo spéciale pour
nous en parler
je vous dirai tout à ce moment là
l'enjeu concurrent spotify deezer les
plus gros un peu de musique
il a d'autres qui existe là plano donc
je ne sois pas en tant qu'art et tout ça
mais je vous en reparle très bientôt
donc que le reste est connectable haut
niveau si ce n'est pas déjà le cas
salut j'ai une question quand tu prends
le one plus gros et offre les écouteurs
avec alors les bullets wireless non mais
par contre c'est une obligation légale
en france d'avoir des écouteurs intégrés
dans votre boîte on coche quand vous
achetez un smartphone en france vous
devez avoir de façon purement légale des
écouteurs à l'intérieur des écouteurs
généralement une prise jack
s'il y en a encore posé coûtera qu'une
prise usb c'est ça c'est une obligation
légale
c'est pas ton logement
dort et mange alors le studio sinon
c'est pas mon logement c'est uniquement
le studio professionnel pour tourner ce
n'est qu'un lieu pour tourner j'y mange
le midi parce que livre la bosnie n'a
gagné gagnage et boit des coups à deux
placements de produits des deux marques
différentes mais voilà ça c'est pas du
tout un endroit dans lequel dans lequel
je vis pourquoi ne fait-il pas des
comparatifs sur sa chaîne ça ce serait
ça nous ferait vachement plaisir votre
vie doit pas de comparatif parce qu'en
fait c'est un exercice qui compliquait
les comparatifs parce que c'est les
compagnons smartphone gestion va
préparer un deuxième voire un troisième
jeu pour faire une vidéo avec 4,5
produit 4 5 smartphones différents
c'est un peu compliqué en fait à faire
le comparatif et puis il fait déjà
beaucoup de vidéos sinon plus à faire
parce que là je vous parle du minho
flights il doit faire un comparatif avec
le minatd et l'unaf des pros le mil neuf
je sais pas quoi s'il y en a pleins 2009
avec un autre smartphone concurrent ça
fait que des comparatifs un peu
compliqué il doute vient cette passion
de l'ateq de camp elle date alors la
surmonte cette steger tête-à-tête 8 9
ans je voulais acheter mon premier
ordinateur d'efg am stram la cassette
cpc 464 pour être très précis et j'étais
très intéressé déjà par essayer de voir
un peu les ordinateurs comment ça marche
le comment perdre dans l'informatique
c'était dans les années 80 donc autant
vous dire d'accepter très longtemps et
puis après en brandissant les questions
sont posées comment est ce que la
technologie changent le monde de quelle
manière et technologies influent sur les
sociétés et comment ça c'est une
mutation fait qui s'opèrent là dessus il
est inclus qui m'intéressent vachement
de peloton beaucoup de réflexion un peu
philanthropique philosophique à six
levées comme ça donc latex ç'a toujours
été un sujet de fond et puis je trouve
on a quasiment tous en objet
technologique avec quasiment montre
smartphone pour la plupart internet
la technologie nous touche tous d'une
manière ou d'une autre donc pour moi en
tout cas c'est un vrai sens ça fait
partie de nos vies donc surtout qui me
plaît qui m'attache depuis très
longtemps qu'elle soit en fait
absolument pas voilà première faq simple
pause est clair sur un bureau comme ça
dans le nouveau studio à vous ne posez
vos questions pour la prochain évacuant
pas directement commentaires je sais pas
si on la fera ici on le fera à
l'extérieur je parle je parle je parle
je parle même plus à parler je pars
bientôt à new york peut-être qu'on
pourrait importer te fais un petit
effectué là bas si vous avez des
questions dont vous pouvez marquer tout
ce que vous voulez en bas je traîne pas
de ma voix parce que jean marc est en
train d'en avoir deux joues lui que j'ai
14 ans vous pouvez marquer toutes vos
questions suggestions interrogations
directement bancomat apoula
prochaine faq et en plus si vous voulez
faire ça pour être très cool pourquoi
pas une petite vidéo
pourquoi pas si c'est le capot de
l'envoyer par mail à hello @ monsieur
gros point fr uniquement dans le cadre
de la faq une petite vidéo uniquement
une petite vidéo qui va les mêmes que
pour le contact professionnel
mais si elle la vidéo ça peut être fun
qui pourquoi pas mal à vous de jouer
tataouine en trouve de demain nous
embrasse ciao